we now know which ps plus and xbox gold
games are free for november oculus quest
is being renamed to meta quest and two
tomb raider games are coming to the
switch in 2022 i'm persia and this is
your gamespot news
it's a big big month for playstation
plus as sony is offering up six free
games for november players can look
forward to knockout city first class
trouble and kingdoms of amalor
re-reckoning and to celebrate the fifth
anniversary of psvr sony is offering
three psvr games including the
persistence the walking dead saints and
sinners and until you fall ea's dodge
brawl game knockout city is the newest
of the group for non-vr games having
released in may this year and is now
running on the new 4k 120 fps update
first clash trouble is a multiplayer
survival game with imposter elements and
saints and sinners is a vr game set in
the walking dead universe
kingdoms of amilor re-reckoning is the
re-release of the 2012 rpg featuring
various upgrades and dlc bundled in
until you fall is a final fantasy sword
fighting game for vr while the
persistence is a space-faring sci-fi
game set in the year 25-21
octobers for ups plus games are still
available so be sure to claim them now
before they're gone on november 2nd
microsoft has announced the games with
gold lineup for november 2021 as well
and there are four titles in all on the
way throughout the month as usual there
are two xbox one games and two backwards
compatible titles the lineup for
november includes 2020s moving out from
november 1st to 30th and this is a co-op
game where players work together to move
items out of a house as fast as possible
there's also going to be lego batman 2
dc super heroes from november 16th to
30th this is a comic book lego game
originally released in 2012 the other
two titles are rocket night which is
available from november 1st to 15th and
it traces its inspirations back to
sega's sparkser series and then kingdom
2 crowns from november 15th to december
15th in which you play as a monarch in
feudal japan be sure to grab the
remaining october 2021 games with gold
titles now before they expire
facebook is retiring the oculus branding
alongside facebook's plan to rename
itself meta it has announced plans to
rename the oculus line of vr products to
align them with the new name for the
overall company the news was shared in a
post by facebook cto andrew bosworth who
said the shift will begin in early 2022
oculus quest will become meta quest
while the oculus app will be renamed the
metaquest app bosworth also said in the
post that vr will be the most immersive
way for people to access the metaverse
and as we look towards our goal of
bringing 1 billion people into vr we
want to make it clear that quest is a
meta product for this reason we're
simplifying our brand architecture and
shifting away from the oculus brand last
year facebook made the controversial
decision to eventually require a
facebook account for all oculus device
users including all new adopters as of
october 2020. however bosworth also
revealed that new ways to log into
quests that won't require a facebook
account are being added and will land
sometime next year further details
weren't shared but it's an encouraging
development nonetheless we recently
reviewed resident evil 4 vr on the soon
to be meta quest so check that out if
you haven't already
the tomb raider series will make its
debut on nintendo's switch in 2022
crystal dynamics has announced this as a
part of the franchise's 25th anniversary
celebration lara croft and the guardian
of light and lara croft and the temple
of osiris will be released on switch
beginning next year the games are being
brought to the switch by feral games in
collaboration with crystal dynamics
farrell previously handled the switch
part of alien isolation guardian of
light is an isometric action game
originally released in 2010 while temple
of osiris debuted in 2014 both games are
spin-offs that feature lara croft
fighting ancient evils and going on
adventures solo or in co-op they were
generally well liked upon release as
mentioned this is the first time that
the tomb raider series is coming to the
nintendo switch whether or not any of
the mainline series games are coming to
the console remains to be seen
which tomb raider title do you think
should be the next one to come to the
nintendo switch let me know in the
comments below and of course leave a
like subscribe and don't miss your next
gamespot news update have a great
weekend and we'll catch you guys next
time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you